let's open up the debate to a chief
economist stylish meeting from the
batting bag bunk thank you very much for
coming in nice to see you again do you
think the four thousand euro subsidy in
Germany has been a flop well subsidies
come at the expense of taxpayers so we
need to really think is there a benefit
to society to justify the subsidy clean
air is a benefit helping an innovation
towards clean air does make some sense
more in order i would say an initial
subsidy of the magnitude up to 4,000
euros can make sense but it has to be
limited targeted and has to be scaled
down over time it sounds good of course
not many people are using it but I guess
minimal cleaner air as a result but why
tell me why these subsidies are not
kick-starting the sector they've been
trying to get this started sub-sector
going to such a long time we probably
need a bit more time until the
technologies amor dime until the
technology is developed enough and
especially judging by the experience of
your reporters it might be helpful to
have a few more charming station say at
public buildings which probably cost
less rather than having this blanket
subsidy I think one of the key reasons
of course people aren't using it very
much is if we can't be sure to actually
use it on a longer distance that we may
refrain from buying it by and large this
is Newt somewhat newest technology there
is some case for limited government hug
it ought to be targeted and maybe
charging stations would be better than
the current subsidy what will get you
into any car would a lot have to change
or just the technology I'll have to see
if for driving in the city it really
makes sense I could eventually think
about it but at the moment I would say
the technology doesn't look develop
enough at least to convince me yet we'll
see and what's your opinion on subsidies
in general not not just for the electric
car industry is it a bad way to run an
economy in the end too much subsidies
are a bad way to run an economy because
subsidies come at the expense of
everybody if many things are subsidized
then the basic effect is that everybody
pays into the subsidies
but nobody really knows who actually
benefits how the limited number of
targeted subsidies makes sense for
technologies that improve the quality of
life for everybody create air once again
is one of these things but blanket
subsidies or subsidies just to help
struggling industries do not make a lot
of sense change including economic
change is part of the game I think the
solar panel case is very interesting in
Germany again another clean energy
supply but as soon as those subsidies
were pulled by the government that
sector flocked there was and is an
argument for subsidies for that sector
but you have to be careful a the subsidy
has to be limited be once there has been
some time to kick start a new technology
the subsidy has to be scaled back in a
way that companies know about in advance
so that they can plan too much of a
subsidy or too sudden a stop to subsidy
political changes to subsidies do not
create value they actually are bad for
business and what about energy subsidies
in general critics say they gobble up
money enrich the middleman and bad for
the planet I think energy subsidies in
general are not good we may need to
invest some money into the public grid
system in Germany that would help quite
a bit but a lot of the ways in which we
subsidize energy in this country is
actually not good for taxpayers and
consumers it is just expensive
rationalizing subsidies cutting them
focusing on the things which are really
important would make much more sense mr.
Schmieding thank you very much for
coming in today